you said earlier that um
it's it's unacceptable so what would
make dating acceptable in your view
or women today well it it's a it's a
long laundry
list but frankly if women honored their
word uh if they started
acting like equals i think the biggest
uh
thing i have against my dating
experiences in the past and what i've
witnessed with my uh my clients is women
saying
i will show up and then they don't i
think the flaking and the lying i think
that is
that would be the biggest improvement
women could do or if they don't want to
go out with the guy just say
you don't want to go out with the guy
and you're not interested um
i think women reaching for their effing
wallets would be a nice
little you know treat um and and that
did happen i know maybe back in your day
in the 90s there was
i have to give my hat and tip my hat to
the gen x gals
because they would reach for their
wallet occasionally and and they they
did make an
effort uh but then towards the later
years of my uh
my dating career um man you might as
well have gotten suppliers to pull teeth
to get these girls
to to reach for their wallet um and then
also just uh it sounds
idealistic but can you girls
conversate can you i mean like if you're
just gonna be an
npc and sit there and wait for the man
to entertain like i don't know how many
dates you went through where you were
like trying to entertain
and trying to be funny and witty only
because you didn't know any better and
you should have just ended the date but
i think uh
you know the guy is also a separate
sentence entity
and maybe if you'd like to go on the
date you girls could bring more to the
table than just sitting there and like
amuse me
uh and for god's sake you know
it's it's a it's a long shot but maybe
you girls are educated about current
events
or you have an opinion or you know a
little bit about philosophy
so that the guy can you you're you're
not just this uh i've literally had like
hang on i got a
i think this is a triceraton oh not uh
what is a raptor this is a raptor's
tooth a friend of mine a fan sent me the
raptor's tooth
dinosaur i've had more interesting
conversations with this raptor tooth
than i have most of the girls i did it
because the raptor tooth is actually
interesting
and has a history in it uh the girls
that when you know a guy
takes all the effort and energy takes on
all the risks takes a
young goes up asks the girls out faces
rejection which is
should be par for the course and then
you say yes and then you just show up
you don't bring anything to the table
it's like
yeah that that so i i'd like women to
talk
you don't want to hear about their
social justice causes or their
modeling career on instagram well
thankfully i haven't dated
uh that recently so i'd lord knows but i
do remember in the olden days where
there were times i should have i should
have just like picked the girl up
and even before i made the right turn
onto the highway said like
okay you're just gonna sit here and and
suck away my time i should turn around
dropped her back off and and that would
be
uh something ideal but you and you know
we might as well be asking for platinum
bars to be falling out of the sky by
that point
yeah um i can't disagree with a lot of
that it's it's you know it's tough to i
mean i
you know the only thing that i would
challenge on that a little bit would
probably be like the expectation that
you're expecting
to have a deep interesting conversation
i mean
you're not gonna discuss solving cold
fusion or something like that when
you're out on a date with a chick it's
just not gonna happen
but um i was talking to somebody about
that earlier today actually
you